I suppose associated with that poverty headspace. Is the concept that. Money is bad money's evil. That.
The whole idea of. Counting and being aware of money. As i thing is is an evil process. And that then.
Develops a desire to not knowing a whole poverty headspace. Because it's in its more moral.
To be poor or to at least think your poll. Is more moral. Thing that strikes me about that poverty headspace.
Is that it misses a couple of really important issues that are not of the poverty headspace
but of the money being evil. And suffice. Money of course doesn't exist anywhere in the first place.
That's a total figment of our imagination. Other than the pipe out that doesn't exist and the print.
That is sitting on it. If we didn't know the language that it was written in.
If we were from somewhere else it could be just as much as the classic of toilet paper.
It doesn't actually have any value in itself and doesn't really exist. It's purely the.
Figment of our imagination and the value that our imagination puts on it. If all the money in the world. Was destroyed.
At the moment. The world would not be one bit. Poorer.
We would still have all of the cars all of the houses all of the. Everything's that we actually use.
We would not have lost one thing. But the whole place would be in total confusion. Total mass. Total depression.
Everyone would be totally lost and i will. Because of one particular magic. Somehow because of this. We had lee.
Figment of our imagination thing called money. People. Each morning.
Billions of them actually get out and go out and work long hours and. Try really hard.
In order to get these pieces of paper because they trust that somehow having these pieces of paper. They trust that.
Other people will give them. All the things that they want. Up to that level. So that. Money. In fact. Creates trust.
Amongst four billion people. Every morning of the day. Because of money.
Four billion people think they can trust each other to some degree. At least a little bit.
Anything that creates that much trust. Cops be all bad. But i also bought a systems.
Have the inherent problem of having the thing that you actually want in the other person's hand right at that time.
The systems beyond that of the credit system this way.
You know are in fact transferring laiva from one person to another.
Basically require a good solid computerize ation and an awareness of what work is being done in the community.
You can have it. Working as a. Occurs in the cities. At the moment. Amongst tradesmen who in fact are working.
With a child up on other projects anyway. And so they're aware of the. Quality level of the other people and.
That i essentially getting. Part of their spending.
What they might be doing godling landscaping they're getting part of their regular spending part. Dealt with simply by.
Live about from one to another.
But that's really a fairly specialized in those circles where they know each other already. The real challenge.
To get a community working well in terms of i live employment a high unemployment. Valley.
Getting the actual an employment level to drop. For instance.
The challenge with that is to actually take in the economics of the whole valley.
To understand what is occurring economically throughout the whole valley.
Into their full have sense of understanding of reality of what this life. Credit is really doing. In the everyone.
In the work. Economics. In the. Everyone getting up every day and going. And working. Economics.
And you actually build up a visual picture of the whole valley.
And what's occurring and the people doing all these different work spot that. You couldn't do it without i can.
As a pretty complex computer level. And you would therefore. Expect a fair degree of. Telephone connection through.
To the to the various parts of the community. Enough to actually satisfy a constant contact. Into the computer.
To verify any any. Important transactions. That whole. Option. And sort of. Has the the comprehensive complexity.
Where a lot of people in the existing community.
Would want to keep talking and arguing about whether that was a good idea for five hundred years if they could.
The level of questions that would come out.
About whether that was definitely what the whole community should do would run forever.
The only way to actually test that out would be. To do it to. Floated as a test place.
But getting enough people to agree about that float. It would mean that you would actually have to.
You would have to see a million dollars in materials and either live or go in to get it to actually be tested.
You know as well why because in order to keep away from that house. Problem. And the. Live value. Past problem.
You would actually have to have some form of currency. In the transaction currency. Swap between that.
Internal credits and. The dollar. If you didn't have that.
Then people would be lieve losing their freedom from poverty. And i would be caught. And i would.
All this work was outdoing would be nontransferable.
And just like the house that's only worth a half or a third of what it's really worth. But i would likewise.
With all their libre. Be caught in a situation where they would. We have to transfer the value.
That's why at the moment you've only got in the eyes. Bought a credit. Systems that are occurring.
People can only afford to do maybe a quarter. A fifth of their total lie about. In that way.
But in him and with such a huge employment unemployment problem. One quarter one fifth.
Might be very good but that's not going to solve. The question here. We get it this. Is. The first.
The first problem with. Getting. Tunnel falls legal and. In existence. I was am requirement. Of the cooperative.
Registrar that trying to shy cancel. Had to give its approval. To the development. They had to give its approval to.
I lodge number of houses being built on this one property.
Which technically up to that time when a family normally being a lad. In three or four houses.
And the registrar of car produce was saying that therefore. It might be illegal it might be. I reduce.
If a lot of people hundreds of people bought shares in a car for dave that was and they are going to be
and i had three of four houses. So we had to go to trying to shock cancel and. Luckily we had a doctoring.
And health department. Building inspector who was very supportive and friendly and helpful. And i suppose it.
It's likely helped in the background economics of the whole place that.
The property had not yet been purchased and now purchase. Would be dependent upon. The approval being given.
Also the particular property. He's in a separate valley from the name and. Town and. Actual name and valet.
Side had eye. Privacy. For the rest of name than. Really out of sight out of mind. You know. In a large pot. And aside.
In the event. Yeah i put forward the submission and. Spoke a little bit and. Luckily this.
Extremely conservative rural. National party country party at that time.
The shire and agreed to a stratus largest commune. Being established inside to run your shot. Well.
It was initially about a thousand and forty ton of all foals. Was it.
It was initially about one thousand and forty if i remember. Ickes.
The original purchase price was right by the owner in the process of the seven months. Between the original agreement.
And the final. Signing of the transfer of contract. Documents. It was. I think it.
I think it changed up to one hundred six thousand dollars. The thing.
He did just on one hundred thousand or just below. And gotten it done.
So there's a thousand acres one hundred thousand essentially. One hundred dollars an acre. For.
What was the hof forest. I guess the reason why i did not style. Town of all. It's it. That's. That's a double.
It's not is that simple that i had to because my level of friendships. At town of all falls. Such that.
I never at any particular time decided to not study a ton of befalls.
Because i new york a wiseguy back at any time that i wanted. But i'd never actually build a house a ton of them.
Because i was too. Involved trying to get various community projects going. And so i had never had a house.
And so i went i then got involved with the. Bush factory. Starting the co-operative down here.
And it was obviously going to need a huge amount of if it and. Just in time and. All the long bits and pieces.
And also at that time. Because i was on this most city council.
And having a place down here at the factory mention that. I didn't have a slight hitch. Because i didn't have a cot.
And i was hitching into council meetings. And not having a saw to hitch. It was suddenly a very useful. Sort of.
Easy step. Easy change. Oh. Well. It was in north in seventy six. That. Bob matias.
Who had been the policeman during the aquarius festival.
And had now been transferred by the police department out to more radio. Some such place. And had.
Therefore decided that he had to sell them all but a factory in name and. And i was approached by.
Bessel height asking whether i wanted to have it and. I had beene.
Working on the registration now if i had in fact to yes receive their instruction. Of bush cooperative.
The i'm a bush property. Going to concentrate on job creation and.
So we've looked at a possible shop operator in the center of town. And that didn't work out. At that particular time.
And then suddenly this often came up. And so i said that well.
When i said to him straight away yeah that's great
and took it along to our coverage of making the car pretty sort of said well that sounds great idea how we got him.
Finance it. And we arranged errands for the whole thing to help put your ass. Was.
The development of the factory and his running. I suppose the. The first thing that was occurring here.
Was bush supplies. Which was i.e. Food. I think call party of business. That began a ton of before us.
And had been part of the essential group that had become involved to register. To form bush cooperative.
And it was the first use in the old cold. Cauldrons. Of the bought a factory. And following on from that.
In pretty quick close succession. He was that he would push the eta and some of the end times. We should design.
Some elaine times. Was started by. Bob craven and patricia size.
Who picture she is now one of the key workers in this more eco. And. That i started the silent times. With i.
Couple of other people. And. Worked it right through until finally some of the end times close i started.
As i think sometime in seventy seven or seventy eight. And ran through to ninety ninety three and three shiny four.
And then the theatre. And lighted the theatre and gained a sort of café restaurant with. And their recording studio.
And. Lyta our studios in a candle workshop. Photographic. Workshop. And i'm semi artistic. Semi. Of all.
The candles and beautiful but i suppose it's more. Of just a normal. Production business. Those. You know.
Well like i haven't really stuck together in there come in. It's certainly not as though i had begun. The.
That is businesses that were most of them started. I under the umbrella of the bush car party.
But at a certain point of time. The bush darpa devoted itself out of existence. Decided to wind down.
And it voted for the factory to be turned into a strata total. Instead of by. And barak offered it as a whole.
And then. The individual rights groups were then naggin first option. On the particular. Spices.
That i using at that time. And most of them stayed and continued. Oh yes it was originally company out strata of.
Bill and. A close was the interest for the sinai. Well it was an interesting.
It was an interesting development it's it's certainly been very successful. And it started in.
I suppose it's out of the century because. I'd been looking at. The questions with the corporative.
At the bush factory. And one of our options instead of going to strada total. At bain to really develop.
My company title. And because of.
Various arguments we ended up going strada
but in the process of that i'd really looked at the question of company title.
Which is i talk of taught all that is very common in eastern suburbs sydney. Of all the flights.
That will go before start to talk to existed which was only in the sixty's i think.
At the for that all of those flights and being. Iran used illegally and a company tata. And i had odd.
Sudden i connected the idea of the company title. Through into i walk advancing. And.
Suggested talk to about that with a tiny part got a and. Hey felker. That didn't work and. That was.
Was i a good combination and. So i then set about designing. In the broad sense. Of all of the. Of the bill includes.
Community. Looking at that. For the right piece of land.
And i suppose that place of vanier's chosen mainly because of my. I ate huge amount of. Individual privacy.
That it gives to sun many and i had one hundred houses. But they've all got such a huge sense of privacy.
We've got a full spectacular. Especially of sunsets. And. It could do that.
On a property that was going to be a very very little. Economic use. For anyone else.
It was laying that would basically be wasted as a as a farm. Because it was such a rough. Property. That.
Farming would be continually just. I hear. I also felt that it. The property would continually have a weed problem.
In terms of laying town or lots of noxious weeds and. That because of that. One of the best ways was to get it off.
The sort of cattle land. Which didn't really. Cope with that. And get it into. I crossed a village.
That would have one hundred families interested in. Beautifying. The different parts of the valley.
And i think that's worked very well that way. So. Oh oh. Oh. I search me. Yes. After some years. Bill and then.
Made arrangements with the lismore city council to become a strata title. After starting off as a community title.
That's hard as a company talking. There was another. Option which would become a valuable now.
But which at the time when they really wanted to make the change. Was not about. I knew talk or title called.
Community title. Which was basically i heard of that company. Title. On a multiple occupancy. But with i.
A specific example with a specific. Fixed. Around me and see if a company title. Can be any number of a range months.
Of that. Whatever your lawyer chooses. And likewise before it existed.
The strata taught all strata title was one particular company title. Which was then fixed by law.
As always having this particular patent. So therefore a solicitor. Could not just change. Some small parts of it.
Which created by. Confusion. And likewise community title is another of those except that it's designed for out.
Door areas without. Interconnecting buildings. Strata title is for places where there is. Walls.
That are shared walls and such things. So. They didn't have community title. At the time. And billing cliffs.
Chose to become part of the start of title. In the process of doing that and most likely will.
At fixing their relationship to each other more. Then on i. General. Commune modoc walk up and say in this area.
Because a lot of the. Desire a lot of the desire to not address questions. In the early days of newman.
Was a desire for greater freedom. That when setting up town of all falls we had the place paid for.
Well there was a sort of one natural. Wing. Which said ike i well.
We've made enough decisions to get the place pipeful we don't need to make any more decisions now.
Now we can just let the place be free and just let the place do whatever it wants to and i'm the let me be free
and do whatever i want to. And i promise not to hurt anyone else and.
Their reality is that when you have that many people living together.
You always have conflicts and differences of opinion.
No matter how much people try not to hurt each other because people always look at.
Things in their life magazine trickly. I can't. It's impossible.
Whenever i've in their eyes i look at everything i guess enter clee then we see the world from where their eyes are at
the time. And automatically whenever they look at things occurring between their house and. The street the road.
They look at the mega century clee. So they have differences of opinion an argument.
And that sort of question comes back to.
Do you try to suggest a structure to minimise those differences of opinion and i. Humans. Just as.
You create a structure for traffic. On roads. To try to minimize the number of accidents.
You know this is not mass individualists and i think. If you look at history. The point about history is that.
Every time you move from something like no magic society. We've curry's. Around this district. And then.
Even if you take those same people. And put them in an agrarian society.
Where the farms are fixed and where they can't just follow the kangaroos.
Across the whole valley and kill them wherever they want because
when i go from one to the other they're on someone else's farm. Even if you look at it. In that terms.
It takes a different set of moral ethics. To live in an agrarian society than. In an emetic society.
And it takes another set of moral ethics to live in a mechanical or a post mechanical world. The greater freedom.
If you want to have absolute freedom of anything.
Of any action that you want to take at any time you need to live by yourself. You need to leave.
As non-medically as you possibly can as far away from other people.
Because if you don't then there'll be some differences of opinion at times. And that will restrict your freedom.
In some way. And this is a whole series of. You know. Come back to when. You think. You know the way that newman is.
You. You know the image of the commune. I mean everyone sharing. So much everything. Is. It's really strange to.
Test that out in reality. And whether. What part of that sharing. Was as limited as into a small household.
How much of that sharing like a plane. Was then limited by. Ok but let's not make any rules. That. The sharing is.
Ike i will agree to share as long as i can have as much as i want. All right.
I see that this sharing in the question of how much sharing was occurring in the early days is immediately.
Intricately linked with. The question of freedom. I you sharing something. If you can have as much as you want.
It goes back to then the number of people. As the number of people have increased in the valley. The continual lesson.
It keeps keeps coming that. We need to really share. Now no i mean really share this time.
We need to really share where you can't have just. Any think that you.